I've heard this urban legend of a
gorilla that lives in the sewer systems
he's gotten smarter he wants more like
him he wants kids I'm pretty sure one
telepathic Grape Ape is more than enough
for this city I still don't have my
speed
hey youtubers is Charlie gorilla grodd
is coming let's break this trailer down
then I'm gonna do my Q&A video at the
end of this so here we go
the big a story of the episode as you
can see his caitlin snow getting
abducted by krod him wanting more like
him i think that's just a tee up for
gorilla city or at least sola bar which
is just blow my mind if they ever got
the chance to do gorilla City that would
just be so crazy the most cartoony thing
that they've done all year so far is
king sharks so I'm interested to see if
they topped themselves I mean before
they brought him on last year you think
that something like this would only work
in a cartoon but they totally made Grodd
work then they made king shark work so I
think they can totally make gorilla city
work in a certain point now if you
haven't read the comics you don't know
what gorilla city is gorilla city is
basically just the society that rises up
around Grodd and Sola bar now Gorilla
Grodd has traditionally been a villain
when he got his powers in the classic
comics there was another ape who was a
good character named solovar who also
got powers who kind of battled it out
with Grodd he was like this riff on
Planet of the Apes where you have bad
apes that want to take over humanity
then you have good Apes that want to
coexist so Lavar was just a good part of
that equation but as we've seen on the
show so far gorilla grodd is the only
super smart ape so either they're gonna
change his character just a little bit
make him a little bit more complex or
they're gonna create a solovar to battle
it out with them as they try to further
a gorilla society and the really cool
thing about gorilla city is that it's
highly technologically advanced the
gorillas are so smart that they found a
way to cloak it from the rest of the
world obviously a lot of the superheroes
of the planet know where it is but
normal people have absolutely no idea
that it exists if you guys are familiar
with Star Wars Canon it's kind of like
the planet Kashyyyk the wookie planet
highly technologically advanced but they
all still live in trees like their
ancestors did so super smart gorillas
create a city live in trees but the
technology is on par with what you would
find in STAR Labs so that's like way off
in the distance this episode is mostly a
King Kong allegory the and arrow
character being caitlin snow now if
you've never seen King Kong she's like
the actress that gets caught by King
Kong but she ends up sympathizing with
him like oh he just wants to live his
life in peace why don't we just leave
him alone
so Caitlin snow as you can see starts to
sympathize with Grodd he just wants
another one like him and Cisco's all
like I'm calling
on this we don't need more
super smart gorillas so that's the big a
story and as you can see it looks like
Harrison wells of Earth two tries to
dress up in a bar thawne's reverse-flash
costume to try and get Caitlyn back the
B's story is Barry getting his speed
back after his battle with zoom now it
looks like he gets his legs back and
then he has some sort of mental block
that he can't get over like there's
nothing wrong with your legs you should
have your speed back there's something
inside you that's stopping you from
accessing your powers
so Barry has to get his groove back in
order to react cess the Speed Force but
the fun of the episode is is that he
goes full-blown eobard thawne riding
around in the wheelchair until he does
and we get to see his dad come back I
know a lot of people want John Wesley
Shipp to be zoom I feel like he's
definitely high on the candidate list
I'm still holding out for Wally West -
like he's still on my list there but
just be prepared to adjust your
expectations based on Clues we get in
future episodes if you remember last
year in episode 9 when they revealed
Harrison wells is the man in the yellow
suit I'm not really expecting a reveal
that big in episode 9 this year but I do
think that we'll learn a lot more about
who it is
like we learned Harrison wells was the
man in the yellow suit we didn't learn
that he was a bard Thawne in disguise
until much later in the season so just
expect a reveal on par with that like we
might learn a little bit more about
zooms plan like why it's so important
for him to be the fastest flash in the
multiverse but I'm not expecting him to
rip his hood off that would be a big
surprise I would flip my if that
happened so here we go onto questions
I'm just gonna pick from the flash first
and I'll do some arrow questions David
Lake and asks Henry Allen is zoom you
say in all caps well it would be poetic
like Thomas Wayne and Robert Queen on
earth - I definitely think it would be
really interesting if he were zoom but
but I also believe that this season
there's a lot more about irises family
so I'm hoping that zoom is more central
to that for those that are asking about
Robert Queen - that'll be a lot of fun
I'm not expecting that actor to come
back and do any Green Arrow stuff on the
flash I think that was just meant as an
easter egg
Sullivan Wilbur asks zoom is not anyone
because Harrison wells created zoom get
it I think you meant that more as a joke
but I do like the idea that zoom is just
like a manifestation of the negative
Speed Force or just a manifestation of
the Speed Force itself like he is not an
actual person the reason that's not true
though is that Harrison wells of earth-2
said that zoom used
to be a human being so he actually is a
person that will see eventually the
really interesting thing about his
character though is it sounds like he's
super evil because Tony Todd just sounds
so scary but it seems like as he's
gotten more powerful it's twisted him
more and more physically and mentally
so zoom before he got his powers may
just been a slightly unstable
personality like he wasn't this grand
villain until he started killing other
speedsters and don't you just wonder if
he's traveled to other Earth's in the
multiverse and killed other speedsters
like earth four five six seven eight
next question from Elm Street asks how
will the flash beat zoom well they
teased it a little bit in this last
episode take his speed out of the
equation the other part is Barry
learning to access the Speed Force more
fully just getting better with his
powers it's the interesting thing about
Barry is is that he's already like at
maximum speed force potential it's just
that his ability to use that speed is
dependent upon his mental state so if he
doesn't think he can do something he
can't do it it's like Yoda with Luke
Skywalker Luke Skywalker doubts himself
so he can't do something so until Barry
stops doubting himself
zoom will always be faster but I think
taking zooms speed out of the equation
will be a big part of defeating him the
other thing I'm hoping for is that Jay
Garrick gets his speed back and we see
another speedster like Wally West as Kid
Flash maybe like we see a flash family
team up to take zoom down next question
Saima and Cookie Monster ask that's the
awesome name wait so episode 8 of flash
is part 1 and arrow episode 8 is part 2
you're talking about the flare Oh
crossover that's right so what's gonna
happen is is after this next week's
episode there's gonna be one week break
then we come back select the first week
in December will be the big flash arrow
crossover this year think of it is like
a two-hour movie that just broken into
two parts so half of it takes place on
the flash the other half takes place on
arrow and the really cool thing is that
they're setting up a whole bunch of
legends of tomorrow stuff like just look
at this picture you see both Hawkman and
Hawkgirl
in full attire now this picture
specifically is from the arrow half of
the crossover so my guess is is that we
meet Hawkman and like the first part of
that he tries to explain to Hawkgirl who
she is what her powers are we learn
about Vandal Savage that's basically the
two-hour episode that's going to
introduce him so that will create the
need
legends of tomorrow for that big team up
and rip hunter to come in the midseason
finales our episode 9
now each show has its own big bad like
damian darhk-- on arrow and zoom on the
flash so they'll have like their own
independent story for episode 9
but episode 8 will be this big shared
story next question moving on to arrow
stuff Matt siegen's asks didn't Felicity
refer to Diggle a Spartan when she was
with mr. terrific new callsign maybe
yeah actually Marc Guggenheim confirmed
that that will be diggle's callsign and
it's not intended to be a comic book
thing it's just supposed to sound badass
remember mr. terrific does not know who
the rest of team arrow is he doesn't
know their identities although he's like
the third smartest person on the planet
he'll probably figure it out but the
call signs are just meant to mask their
identities that's the only reason she
says that next question Jake Astro asks
I think when Damian said new life he was
talking about new gods so this is
actually a bit of a long shot I'm not
expecting that box to end up being a
mother box but it definitely looks like
it could be one
the thing about arrow this season is
that it's supposed to be all about
mysticism and magic so I'm actually
thinking that it's gonna be something
more magically based which I guess you
can consider new guys territory but I
think the plot will somehow dovetail
with legends of tomorrow I'm expecting
Vandal Savage to be part of hive so
don't hold your breath on new Genesis or
apocalypse but if Smallville could do a
version of Darkseid then they could
totally do it in this arrow flash
legends of tomorrow universe next
question nas asks do you think that the
political adviser for Oliver is secretly
working for hive do you have any more
guesses about who's in the grave at the
end of episode one but the actor that
they cast seems like he's tied up more
in Thea's storyline than he is in Oliver
so if there's gonna be someone to take
him down eventually or take him on then
I think it's gonna be Thea speaking
about the grave though I'm still
convinced that it's either Quentin or
Diggle Paul Blackthorne is an amazing
actor so it would suck if the show had
to lose him but I could also see how big
his quest to learn more about his
brother would drive him into that grave
him learning about his brother being a
crime lord gave him 0 closure so this
matter is definitely not over with him
but I will say congratulations to this
week's reverse flash ring giveaway
winner Henry Wu be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I get your contact info the next
giveaway will start whenever I post my
flash video this week bunch of awesome
stuff happening I'll try to drop like
the really important news during my
flash arrow videos and I had
been doing Supergirl videos at the end
of the week so if you want to see those
they do exist I have a playlist I'll put
a link in the description
white guys wait for my Walking Dead
video to post tonight you can click here
for all the Star Wars videos that I've
been posting the last couple of days and
you can click here for all my other DC
Supergirl flash arrow videos thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you